[Music]
for you
there'll be no more crying
Christine MCV co-lead singer of
Fleetwood Mac has died she was 79 years
old
[Music]
the singer-songwriter who also played
keyboard for the multi-platinum band
died Wednesday after a short illness
is what we are this is what we do we're
hoping that we'll
you know go on till we drop as long as
we're writing songs and Performing the
way we hope is up to standard
Christine's family confirmed the news
with a statement reading in part quote
she passed away peacefully at a hospital
this morning she was in the company of
her family after asking fans to respect
their privacy at this difficult time
they added quote we would like everyone
to keep Christine in their hearts and
remember the life of an incredible human
being and revered musician who was loved
universally I've always been quite
content you know stuck behind my rule of
ivories I I like that
position I'm not exactly the most
visible of performers in the in the
sense of the word as Stevie is for
example Fleetwood Mac paid tribute in a
joint statement quote there are no words
to describe our sadness at the passing
of Christine McVie she was truly One of
a Kind special and talented beyond
measure we were so lucky to have a life
with her individually and together we
cherished Christine deeply and are
thankful for the amazing memories we
have she will be missed she's magical
Stevie Nicks also remembered her fellow
band member with a personal handwritten
note calling Christine her best friend
since 1975 while sharing Heim lyrics
that represent their friendship people
love to wonder about Fleetwood Mac they
enjoy it well we are a musical soap
opera after all founding member Mick
Fleetwood also spoke out he wrote in
part quote part of my heart has flown
away today I will miss everything about
you you know music's been
the major part of my life and the reason
for for My Success if you want
um and there's still a great joy to me
to to be able to take part in some way
or other Christine's music career began
with British Blues Rock Band Chicken
Shack but after marrying Fleetwood Mac
bassist John McVey she officially joined
his band in 1970.
[Music]
during her time in the group Christine
penned and sang many of its later hits
including think about me hold me and
little lies
[Music]
in 1998 Christine exited the band but
returned in 2014 for Fleetwood Mac's on
with the show tour this is the the 18
years of being wiped I've searching to
really wonder what the hell I did do for
a seniors it's just sort of quite
unbelievable she remained a part of the
group until her final days I just can't
see any end to it I mean as far as I'm
concerned this is what I do this is what
I love doing
foreign